monsters are cool that's just a fact
part of their endless appeal that they
are fundamentally strange and different
to the world that we existed all of us
can sit around and imagine that thing
that would scare us when it goes bump in
the night
but for Turtle Rock Studios they had to
figure out how to articulate that in
such a way that you could control it
that it would become natural as you
unleash your inner Beast
so really an essential component and one
of the signature element of evolve is
the monster um monsters are fantastical
creatures so really there's almost like
a sky's the limit on what you can do
with them what did you know though going
in what you had to do a to have an
exciting monster and one that would be
competitive inside of the game
environment I mean from a visual
standpoint you know we just kind of
don't into it not really sure what we
wanted to do I think the initial goal
was to come up with monsters that you
know something that you'd never seen
below right and so what we ended up with
were some monsters a as works of art
were really cool but you would look at
them and you didn't know what the hell
you were looking at great they were just
kind of so strange that they weren't
really scary 1 & 2 as a monster player
you couldn't connect with them the thing
that we find is you know you want to be
attached to your character right hunters
monsters are no different right I mean
if I'm going to play the monster I want
there I want to have some kind of
connection into that creature right we
gave life lips right so that the
animators to pull them back you know and
have him snarl and you know in eyelids
that can allow them to blink suddenly
they were characters instead of these
sort of abstract pieces of art
there's a lot of function and form that
has to happen they have to coexist at
all times in simultaneously that you
know it has to look a certain way but
that's also going to allow it to control
a certain way because unlike say maybe
an AI control creature that can have
sort of a limited range of behavior this
has to be fully player controlled and be
enjoyable so there has to be sort of a
good range what you can do with it and a
challenge there is you know in most
games with it with a boss battle the
boss has these routines that he runs and
they go through these cycles that are
you figure out the rhythms right and
then you can beat him but as soon as
that is player controlled now there's no
rhythms so now we have to we put tells a
good example would be a Goliath Rock
throat where he he physically goes to
pick up the rock and puts it over his
head and even though that's player
controlled when the player has complete
control of when he releases that rock
I've already seen that he's going to
throw a rock as a player so I'm ready to
dodge right you create these windows and
you got to ride that razor's edge and
that's where kind of the the fun
gameplay comes out between the two teams
when you first started out with the game
with with the monsters where they are
now a lot has happened the the evolution
of Goliath and crack and if you can sort
of detail like what you thought you were
know you were going to be doing at the
beginning and then we can talk about
sort of where is now each monster always
sort of filled a specific role so we
always knew off the bat that Goliath was
the brawler and he needed to get up
close I always close the distance to get
get close to the hunters to sort of seal
the deal when we started it was
originally first-person it was a tedious
affair I guess to say the least to try
to keep track of four guys who are all
just ganging up on you it's just
frustrating for the player like it
wasn't an enjoyable experience we played
the game for a long time and
first-person and one of the things that
we never really saw was the sense of
scale or like change the evolution the
name of the game was something that we
had to sell we knew that much and you
raise a camera up a few feet or even a
couple meters it wasn't really there was
no impact and definitely nothing
exciting getting taller is only part of
it like it's very difficult to sell like
a sense of weight and size it just feels
like you're driving like the crappiest
car ever you know it takes forever to
turn around you know you're trying to
turn the corner and you're just driving
a bow you know and we were trying all
these different things to say like
you're big you're powerful now you can
knock down trees and things but it just
always felt like a frustrating work to
make that happen if we could see the
monster I can sell his weight how big he
is we can could make him look really
cool and you know that's that's you like
why are we hiding the the cool looking
monster we were actually kind of worried
that hey if this third person monster
thing works it might be shut down just
on the premise that it's too different
from the other part of the game and like
maybe that juxtaposition is going to
make sense to people but it was it was
cool because the reaction was wow the
monster they physically our own
experience now the monster is his own
guy the hunters are their own guys you
know
like just kind of this accidental
byproduct that it actually added
something for them to be different so
that was really cool
we say monster and I think we're
conditioned to go bad guy or thing which
I should be very comfortable to load but
really in the game they're remarkable
animals like there's it really isn't
kind of a moral judgement that's passed
on them and you know maybe sort of an
allusion to your rooms that King Kong
you know there's at times I couldn't
help but have a degree of pathos even
when I was a hunter I mean did you
always kind of see it as having I don't
see moral ambiguity but actually a moral
equity between the hunters and and the
monster yeah I think so I mean the thing
that about the monsters that we decided
very early on is we're not telling you
where they're from we're not telling you
what their motivations are right
that's all left to your imagination
certainly when I'm playing as the
monster I feel like I'm the good guy and
they're the bad guys and of course vice
versa right I mean that is one of the
most sort of fun aspects is it is
indulging I think many sort of trials
the fancy so many of us have always had
any what was I assume that must have
been ridiculous fun in the beginning to
just kind of think of the monster the
thing of the monsters sort of rule set
and just come up with like all of that
logic I mean very few people get to have
you know indulgence yeah that was such a
huge opportunity for us being able to
get it signed and actually build the
game that we wanted to make you know and
it was really it was really us sitting
there fantasizing about you know all the
different things that oh and and you
could have a harpoon gun that you can
shoot it would stop the monster but then
he could Schmitt he could break it and
and so going through all of that stuff
and then and actually seeing it you know
become reality is amazing
one of the great pleasures of conducting
these interviews and hopefully for all
of you in watching them is such a
fascinating look at the creative process
of a talented developer the
experimentation the risks own pursuit of
something that wants to be fundamentally
fun what I can see that's been
accomplished but there's one more step
in this creative evolution and that's
all of us playing the game
you